Tom you're so great in this movie as
Hank Williams did you already know that
you could sound like him or did you have
to really work at it I just some work on
it I knew that I basically knew that
this was a mountain I had to climb and I
went down to nashville tennessee and i
lived in the house of a man called
Rodney Crowell who's a very respected
musician in his own right and we just
played and sang for five or six weeks he
was hilarious about it cuz he would say
you know time to boy you got a you're
got your polite Englishman in there and
we got it loosened him up a bit we got
to shake him out we got it you're
singing right on the beat we got to sit
you back off the beat you got you're
singing the blues now
and Lizzie you have a tough line to walk
in this because we're told that your
character isn't considered the best
singer well the thing is
she can't be so bad that it makes him
look like a huge idiot or herself look
like she's just completely in denial but
um she says she walks a few lines you
know being a bad singer being maybe the
month not most a pleasant person I was
also fascinated mark to learn in the
movie that there was a lot of industry
resistance to lovesick blues which ended
up being one of Hank Williams's biggest
hits his manager and publisher thought
that the song was kind of not very good
but it broke through and it became his
first really big hit moving on over Lucy
had lovesick turned him into a rock star
before I let you go all three of Europe
Music heads what's your favorite thing
that you're listening to right now I
can't think of anything right the moment
did I say but I could tell you what I
hear constantly yeah my five-year-old an
eight year old singing mean by Taylor
Swift okay that's the soundtrack of my
life mean okay I recently saw ex machina
and there's that dance sequence where
they were asking Oscar Oscar dances to
get down Saturday night by Oliver
Cheatham okay I'm crazy about that song
I think it's a I think it's a real it's
a disco classic something
you